en el año 1944 el peso de una
computadora era de 4.500 kilogramos una
computadora portátil moderna pesa
alrededor de 2.7 kilogramos cuál es la
proporción del peso entre una
computadora de 1944 comparada con el
peso de una computadora portátil moderna
expresa tu respuesta como la razón entre
dos números enteros pues bien para
encontrar la razón o proporción entre
dos cantidades pues yo tengo que tomar
la primera que me dicen son los 4500
kilogramos de la computadora de 1944 y
si esto lo expreso como el cociente con
los 2.7 kilogramos de una computadora
portátil moderna he obtenido la razón o
proporción que hay entre ellas pero nos
están pidiendo que la respuesta sea
expresada como la razón entre dos
números enteros algo tendremos que hacer
aquí para tener números enteros tanto en
el denominador como en el numerador y
bien pues una idea que nos viene a la
mente sería recorrer el punto decimal
del 2.7 una posición pero hacer esto es
equivalente a multiplicar por 10 si yo
multiplico por 10 el denominador tengo
que hacerlo en el numerador para
conservar la proporción entonces
multiplico también por 10 y esto es lo
mismo que multiplicar por 10
y de entre 10 o multiplicar por 1 porque
10 entre 10 es 1 y bien veamos a que es
igual esto bueno si yo multiplico 4500
por 10 obtengo 45.000
y en el denominador obtengo 27
y podríamos decir que con esto ya
terminamos pero hay algo más que podemos
hacer con esta expresión que tenemos
aquí y podemos simplificar la observamos
que 45.000 es divisible entre 45 y entre
9 y 27 también es divisible entre 9
lo que vamos a hacer es dividir entre 9
y dividir entre 9 al 27
y lo que voy a obtener es que 45.000
entre 9 es 5000
y 27 entre 9 es igual a 3 y con esto
hemos terminado obtenemos la razón o
proporción que nos solicitan expresada
con números enteros